this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you everybody I didn't hear the
introduction so I apologize I've got
some wonky internet service here at our
facility
so if I do cut out I will be back
um so rest assured
um thanks Jennifer for putting this
together
um looking at some of the previous
sessions that folks have attended I
think it's interesting that the last one
is literally the end of the pipe as far
as food production goes that we're
looking at
um so I manage a rural a fairly small
rural landfill in Lebanon New Hampshire
it serves 22 communities but they're 22
pretty small communities
our population served as about 90 000
people
um
some of those communities are less than
200 people so it's a it's a pretty rural
operation
um but I have a different approach to
the way I look at
um
managing this facility we do have an
active landfill here we have a a robust
recycling program a food scrap program
here at this at this facility
so what I'll be talking about today are
kind of
feels like kind of lessons learned over
the years about food scrap composting
we've been composting food scraps for
about 15 years and
um and I'll get into a little bit of
that during the presentation
[Music]
all right what slide are you looking at
because that's
I've got three monitors here I just want
to make sure I'm looking at the right
one
um it's a green outlined what are we
talking about composting perfect perfect
okay so just with these types of topics
I think it's important to at least
create context
um everybody seems to have a different
definition of composting and compost
um
composting is a form of waste disposal
where organic waste decomposes naturally
under organic Rich conditions
I think that's a pretty Universal broad
definition uh it's Nature's Way of
managing waste you know you go out into
the forest and stick your hand into the
soil that
stuff that you pull up is organic matter
in the process of composting so we have
this vision of composting that includes
equipment like scarabs or front end
loaders and very
resource intensive but composting
happens every day without diesel fuel
um but what we're going to be talking
about is a more
um
a Hands-On approach to composting
so the what I'm looking at is this is a
process by which we make compost and
compost is the end product of the
composting process and there's a bit of
a path in a pathogen reduction and
nutrient acquisition blah blah blah
you're making soil essentially
now for us composting is the you know
triple bottom line it's resource
conservation as Zach mentioned earlier
about uh you know the impacts of food
waste
Mark you have Frozen
foreign
line again okay so it's as the slide
shows it's a you know focused on
resource conservation and Zach gave a
wonderful presentation on on uh the
resources that are going into food waste
I'm not going to get into that detail
um for us there's a financial benefit
um and then ultimately uh there is a
greenhouse gas implication associated
with food waste composting I do want to
point out
um that the food recovery hierarchy
that's presented by EPA is a waste
hierarchy it's so if you look at that
from a greenhouse gas perspective
composting might be in the wrong slot
but from a waste reduction and waste
management perspective it makes all the
sense in the world so be careful on how
you look at some of these Frameworks and
hierarchies it's important to understand
what the end goal is and for that food
recovery hierarchy the end goal is
reducing waste and Zach is a hundred
percent right on that the best way to
manage food waste is to not produce it
in the first place
um our region has some interesting
approaches there's an organization
called willing hands and they actually
pick up
um perishable food before it's expired
from local grocery stores and
redistributes it to senior centers
homeless shelters and things of that
nature food shelves so instead of a food
shelf just being non-perishable food
items they also distribute
um
perishable foods and they have a
gleaning program at the end of the
season where Farmers allow low-income
families to come and glean up in our
region to help reduce food insecurity
and food waste
the other thing that we've done here
through our division in cooperation with
a local food co-op is we've done several
workshops on how to cook with food waste
making things like pesto chicken stock
vegetable stock some things that if you
ask your grandparents would say is a
common practice
but for us it's it's not I saw in one of
the comments the use of milk as a plant
food
you can look at milk as a liquid manure
at that point and it does have nutrient
value
the quantities and stuff I am not a
plant expert but it does have does have
some benefits
but again the important thing to
remember is not producing food waste in
the first place is the more critical
path
so composting for resource conservation
um for us here at the landfill there are
regulations that require us to operate
in a particular fashion so side slopes
have to be controlled for erosion
an area is not actively receiving waste
for 60 days have to have 18 inches of
topsoil or its equivalent placed to
generate or grow grass or some
vegetation so we end up consuming large
volumes of Virgin topsoil as a result so
15 years ago
I looked at that requirement and
wondered is there a way to positively
impact disposal capacity accomplish
erosion control and really do something
beneficial with all of it and it came
down to
extracting organic matter creating a
waste generated soil product
and we did have done that for 15 years
annually we produced between 10 and 15
000 cubic yards of usable product here
at our solid waste facility
um
it results in much better soil Health we
did some tests at one point we
manufactured the topsoil using short
paper fiber and other soil products we
produced our own compost as well as
using topsoil virgin topsoil our product
works the best of the three
um the product that we use at our
facility is a is an unscreened unstable
in some cases compost product uh the
reason we do unscreened is because for
erosion control large sticks and other
large pieces of carbon essentially in
the the compost help divert water and
stop
um the generation of you know little
rivlets coming down slopes so it's it's
actually great for storm water
management and erosion control
um we do produce a compost product
that's used elsewhere in the city as a
mechanism to reduce pesticide and
fertilizer applications throughout the
city I'll get into that a little bit
um but as we talk about this one thing
that I always encourage is composting at
home is the best option Bar None we're
not driving waste around we're managing
it where it's generated we're using it
where it's generated so we've reduced
our transportation footprint
considerably simply by doing hunk home
composting now recognizing that I know
in our area and I'm sure in many of
yours single-family dwellings are not
being built like they used to be there's
a lot of multi-family housing even in in
our community a majority of the housing
projects that are being built are not
single-family dwellings it's
multi-family dwellings that that feel
they don't have access to food scrap
composting so we've we've developed some
drop-off options and I'll get into that
some more but
foreign
so there is a financial benefit we
charge a tip fee
um so we generate Revenue as a result
um there's it's cheaper than landfilling
so for the customer there's a they have
a financial benefit as well
um this image on the screen right now
this is our compostable food scrap
permit for residents so we have two
programs we have a commercial account
program and a residential drop-off this
is our residential drop-off program the
resident pays for the permit
they've basically paid an annual fee
that is the cost of US managing their
compostable products
so they don't have to pay again for the
entire year they pay once they place
this sticker on a five gallon pail and
we accept one five gallon pail per
household throughout the year and that's
typically what
the average household a five gallon kale
is adequate um
some families that have more people in
their family you know larger families
might need more pails and then they
would get multiple permits
um it allows us to avoid soil purchases
you know if we're putting virgin topsoil
down on side slopes as we expand the
landfill as it grows larger and as we
you know move around in the operation
topsoil is expensive even if you can
find it
um and then the other piece of it is you
know this is helping with landfill
capacity
um currently we're diverting about 870
tons of food scraps annually which
equates to two percent of our overall
MSW but it equates to about 10 percent
of the food scrap that's going into the
landfill that we're currently diverting
and this is a totally voluntary program
we don't New Hampshire doesn't have a
mandate city of Lebanon doesn't have a
mandate at this time
um that may change in the future but it
um we're currently diverting about 10
percent of our food scraps available
through our means
so our food scrap drop off for residents
um
with covid that's why our staff person
is wearing a mask
um but the resident drops their food
scraps into a
specific dumpster that dumpster is
taking to our composting area for
processing it's a very simple process
um we're producing a low value product
and I actually say that with pride a lot
of facilities are focused on farming
operations all that we're trying to do
is grow grass so
as a result
we're not concerned if you know somebody
could throw a chocolate cake in there
it's not a problem we take bones and
meat and dairy because we're able to
maintain higher temperatures it'll break
down those food scraps
as you can see
um my staff person is throwing a a bag
of food scraps in there we have a
requirement that the food scraps are
bagged in a compostable bag
that can be paper or a compostable
plastic now I know there's a lot of
a lot of discussion about legitimacy of
compostable Plastics we require that our
compostable Plastic Products are be our
BPI certified
um a couple of years ago BPI
um I think it's biological product
Institute it's a certification of
compostable products they required a few
years ago that their compostable
products not contain pfas because within
the industry they were noticing that a
lot of compostable products were
containing pfas so for those who are not
aware anything that food doesn't stick
to likely contains pfas so because of
the concern with pfas and the toxicity
of the waste stream we require that
composable products be BPI certified so
we take compostable forks and plates and
other utensils from restaurants but we
work with those restaurants to ensure
that those products are certified and do
not contain
nasty chemicals
so this is our food scrap windrow area
for commercial accounts so they drop off
directly in our composting area as you
can see in the foreground there's a
compostable bag
and we mix we have a recipe that we use
we mix a cup two parts yard waste and
wood chips
to one part food scraps and we do
include a small portion of high carbon
wood ash from a biomass plant
part of the reason for that is the uh
the high carbon Ash acts as an odor
control
and you know eliminates odors almost
instantly when applied to our to our
piles
again the feedstocks that we use are
pretty typical of other Solid Waste
operations uh I've broken them down into
carbon nitrogen or Browns and greens
um the the pitcher in the upper left of
the two is our residential drop-off area
so we receive brush which we call clean
wood so for us clean wood is anything
that's not dimensional there are some
facilities that take dimensional Lumber
in their brush area we don't we're very
uh very specific on that because we use
it in our compost operation so it's just
branches trees shrubs things of that
nature
and next to the brush area is our leaf
and yard waste we get it bagged or
people drop off bulk leaves we've worked
with a number of area landscapers to
take their Leaf matter as well as this
time of year can be a struggle for
getting enough carbon
but we've found that working with some
of the local landscapers we actually get
a lot of bark mulch this time of year
because they're cleaning it up you know
last year's mulch is dirty so they clean
it up and we receive that as a kind of
an early carbon shot into our program
we also get wood chips from a number of
area tree service companies and we work
with a few of the utility companies when
they're doing
um right-of-way
vegetation removal so for us anything
that's carbon we take at zero dollars
because for us it's a challenge to get
carbon sources
um a number of of areas up here it's
strange to think well there's lots of
trees around for us people have what's
better known as the back 40 and don't
necessarily bring their leaves to a
solid waste facility so for us it can be
a challenge to obtain adequate carbon to
uh to work with some of the food scraps
so as far as the nitrogen process the
greens as it were represents the food
scraps that we get grass clippings and
we do receive some manures typically
from Hobby Farms
so for those who are not familiar with
what a hobby Farm is it might be
somebody who has five acres of land and
a horse
horses produce 40 pounds of manure a day
and you're not going to spread that
adequately on five acres of land
so we will on occasion get you know
clean outs from Hobby Farms typically
horse manure
and some people will say well horse
manure isn't a good manure it's actually
great if you're composting food scraps
because horses are not ruining you know
they don't have multiple stomachs so
horse manure has got a lot of good
available carbon in it
and very often when horse stables clean
out their horse manure you get a lot of
sawdust from The Stables so it's a high
beneficial source of carbon if
somebody's looking for carbon
there are some places around us too
um that actually receive seaweed it's
really important to understand your
feedstocks and where they're coming from
we don't have a lot of golf courses and
country clubs around us as a result we
don't see a high use of pesticides we do
some basic sampling once a year
but for the most part we're uh we're not
receiving that type of material
a number of years ago
um there was a couple of facilities in
our region that had received some horse
manure and it it ruins their their
compost because the horse stables were
importing hay from Canada and the
Canadian farmers were using a pesticide
called copyrolid which was not destroyed
in the compost process ended up in the
[Music]
um
in the end compost and killed a lot of
broadleaf produce as a result when it
was applied to Gardens which again is
one reason why we don't distribute to
the public
um
Mark you've frozen again
okay are you sorry about that okay so we
lost you at the hey from Canada and uh
why you don't uh share with the public
so that's that's why we don't share with
the public is
um I've managed other programs and all
it takes is um killing somebody's tomato
plants or rose bushes to ruin your
program
um there are a lot of other benefits
um to using product within your
community and I'm going to get into that
as well as far as where our compost is
also distributed not just at the
landfill
so again our end product is a low value
product it allows for greater diversion
a number of organic farmers won't take
compostable Plastics as a result like
our local farmers market is 95 diversion
because we require all the vendors to
use compostable products
um in their food prep so we don't have
any styrofoam and things like that so
it'll
we lost you again
foreign
ERS markets all compostable products
correct yeah and as a result it allows
us to divert far more
um waste from the waste stream and many
of the restaurants in our area that have
decided to move towards compost ability
are able to divert again far more waste
as a result so as far as events Waste
Management we're able to do a lot with
diversion because we have a low value
product and again it's primarily used
for grass production and erosion control
knowing your your end markets is
critical and that's what drove a lot of
it is
um there's a number of there's probably
three composters around us but they're
producing a a farm or homeowner grade
compost
and as a result
um
they don't accept composable products at
their facilities so for us it made a lot
of sense to uh to go with a low value
product there's not a lot of composters
in our area that do that have that
approach
so here's a picture of our landfill
these side slopes anywhere you see grass
at our facility
um it's got compost underneath it and
that's what we use for propagation it's
literally just apply compost and then
spread grass seed and this is what we
get so we're not using tacifiers or
anything like that and in some cases
we're literally manually hand spreading
grass seed in multiple Acres just by
hand so the you know we're not using
fertilizers we're not using tacifiers to
stick to slopes the compost itself is
accomplishing that
and we grow grass quite well here
's a couple of other pictures where our
end compost has ended up the photo on
the left is one of the cemeteries in
Lebanon and in the middle of that photo
is is where we use some of the compost
uh the stuff in the lower right is just
recent construction so the grass isn't
very good but we're using it in the
cemeteries again to avoid pesticide and
fertilizer applications so when a grave
is dug instead of using Virgin topsoil
after the grave is the body is interred
we use compost to to top dress the area
and reseed
on the right hand side is a picture of
an old railroad yard that last year
there were five buildings brick
buildings in that lot and the buildings
were removed
the brick was brought here for
beneficial use in road construction
and then we used our compost to level
off the property and to vegetate so as
you can see what was an ugly railroad
yard is now a nice green Lush yard will
soon be athletic fields to be used by
the public
foreign
house gas reductions
it's interesting there's a there's a
little bit of literature out there about
the implications of greenhouse gas
reductions
um just as a
as an FYI share kind of thing last night
my wife and I watched a movie called
kiss the ground for those who have not
watched it I would encourage you to
watch it
um it's it's interesting it talks about
the impacts of our agricultural system
not just food production but agriculture
as a whole and its impacts on greenhouse
gas production and there's actually a
section on food waste and composting
which I thought was interesting
so some of the greenhouse gas
Productions are obvious and some in my
mind are not so obvious
the obvious ones include not landfilling
food scraps so what you know Zach I
thought it was really great that Zach
included those survey pieces where there
was a large percentage of the population
that were surveyed said well I'm
landfilling it and I'm okay with that
um the problem with landfilling food
scraps is it falls under this
anthropogenic greenhouse gas production
equation piece and what's happening to
food scraps and landfills is first of
all landfills are anaerobic
um
there is this unfortunate myth that
somehow landfills operate like a giant
compost pile and they don't the idea
behind landfilling is actually to
evacuate oxygen and to evacuate moisture
two very critical components in
composting so for farmers who do halage
or silage it's not an unsimilar
operation you know that that task there
is a fermentation process but it occurs
when you remove oxygen and that's what's
happening in a landfill the net result
of food scraps in a landfill are
it's producing nitrous oxide which has
got huge global warming potential as
well as methane
and those are not components that are
that are generated in
appreciable amounts in the composting
process
they are generated to some degree if the
the pile happens to go anaerobic and
that's usually when you get that stink
foul smell if it's just left but a pile
that's managed and turned regularly
produces very little of those um
of those greenhouse gases
so that's a big portion of greenhouse
gas reduction is by composting it you're
not producing those those greenhouse
gases that have a huge global warming
potential
the other piece
um is is the whole Transportation
reduction for us here at our facility
we're producing a compost and using the
compost locally
so the the transportation footprint is
very small we're not importing topsoil
um but we're also not shipping our food
waste out I mean our our landfill is
right here so we're able to manage it
locally but we're also managing the end
product locally
um which reduces our transportation
some of the not so obvious
um benefits of of compost particularly
used at a landfill
compost on outside slopes actually acts
a bit like a biofilter
um compost is used as a biofilter at a
number of facilities like sludge
composting facilities air is collected
in the facility and run through compost
and compost grabs hold of some of these
nasty things that are that are in those
emissions and binds it up in the compost
so by using compost on the outside
slopes any fugitive emissions that might
be coming up through the soils is
grabbed by that compost I don't have any
numbers as far as what the
you know efficacy of that is but it's
just it's an industry practice at um at
composting facility so I just use that
same philosophy here
um to help mitigate some of our fugitive
emissions
not using uh virgin soil products like
topsoil
um for slope stabilization allows for
some carbon sequestration
compost holds carbon so as far as
greenhouse gas reduction
um and just growing grass that operation
in and of itself is pulling carbon out
of the atmosphere into the ground into
the root mass and throughout the soil
and into
um you know that micro layer so
you know stripping topsoil from what
would have been Farmland removes that
potential and actually generates and
releases carbon into the atmosphere when
that that um that soil product is
removed so not doing that eliminates
that and we are able to sequester
um with the use of compost
as I mentioned um the reduced
transportation is not insignificant
managing waste locally reduces
transportation and reduces that
Transportation footprint and trucks run
on diesel and the fewer trucks are
moving around the less diesel emissions
are generated
um and then not importing virgin topsoil
from out of town also has a positive
impact on our transportation footprint
so again food scraps are not shipped out
they're managed locally and the end
product is used locally
again this is that compost applied to
side slopes and having a positive impact
on fugitive emissions
the use and distribution of our end
product as was mentioned before it is
not given out to residents in my mind
there's a a better purpose for that
um and that's used in and around our
solid waste facility we actually produce
two types of compost here one is a food
waste compost and one is a yard waste
compost the food waste compost is used
on the landfill
and the yard waste compost is used
around the city
and it's just
politically it was easier to do it this
way than uh
there is a yuck factor when people learn
that we're using waste products that are
making their way into Parks so because
we use so much compost on site we were
able to just divert food scraps and use
it right on site
and as I mentioned we're using it on the
yard waste compost is used without
um without any issues on our city parks
athletic fields and uh throughout our
cemeteries
it's important to Monitor and test your
compost so we take temperatures of our
piles to watch at our our activity see
what's going on it helps determine
frequency of turning many of the rules
and regulations specify a number of
turns which we're able to accomplish but
we use temperature as a as a deciding
factor on when when to turn
um we do some soil testing just to see
what the nutrient levels are in the soil
which helps with our process we
discovered that we were adding too much
of the wood ash to our pile so that was
changing the structure and nature of our
our end compost so we we've backed off
on that
but it's also important to understand
heavy metals and pfas testing some
people might wonder where might that
stuff be coming from
um you know you'd be surprised what's in
our food scraps
um as far as pesticides and other
chemicals as well as the compostable
products we try to keep as much of the
pfas and and
you know non-certified compostable
products out but it's important to have
an understanding what's going in there
and we monitor our customers but some
things always slip through
some food scrap program considerations
Outreach is critical especially to the
general public there's a lot of
confusion about what's okay and what's
not because we're we're defined as an
industrial compost process that's very
different than your backyard composting
container so what we're able to compost
is very different than what might be
acceptable in a backyard composting bin
um and not all compostables are created
equal
um earlier we were talking about you
know how petroleum products were created
and you know uh fungi weren't available
to break down ligaments
um so lignins are those really hard
thick cell walls in things like trees
and Woody plants that are difficult to
compost so if you're using only wood
chips as your carbon Source you're going
to struggle to produce a good product
and it's going to smell bad because the
carbon is not bioavailable in a wood
chip you need a combination of wood
chips and leaves you know to create that
bioavailable carbon source
knowing your customers as I mentioned
earlier about the golf courses and horse
stables
um or hobby Farmers those are critical
to understand where are you getting your
hay what's your application of
pesticides and fertilizers on grass and
how is that making its way into your
compost operation or not
staff training it took us years to get
my staff to understand
how to turn windrows
and it seems like a simple notion but to
take a bunch of guys who had been
landfilling for for 20 years to try to
get them to manage a pile of waste very
differently it took some time to get
them to understand the importance of
turning and frequency of turning so that
did take some time
we work with our local Cooperative
Extension
um agents to develop a recipe and to
better understand our composting and and
the and compost and how it would be used
um when we get unusual requests
um we we go through the Cooperative
Extension we have a wood stove company
in our area that is a soapstone wood
stove so they have a lot of soapstone
dust
um and when that you know when that was
approached as far as is this a product
we could use in our compost there was
question about its its nutrient
availability and benefit so we do
continue to work with Cooperative
Extension on some of these odd
um odd requests we work with fish and
wildlife services when they have to do
some animal kills or dot our Department
of Transportation when they do pick up
some roadkills so we do receive
carcasses here at our facility and and
they compost very well at these high
temperatures
other issues to consider are site
management like mud and vectors you know
can you access your facility in the
winter not just your equipment but can
your customers access the bins and
things of that nature
foreign
as I mentioned earlier about compostable
products
BPI is the is the organization that we
use
um and there's a variety of companies
out there that that Supply compostable
products
you can get them on Amazon but you can
if you're looking at them and you're
going wow these are so much cheaper
they're probably made in a foreign
country using a lot of pesticides and
other chemicals so it's really important
to understand where products are coming
from and so that's why we focused on BPI
and we worked with BPI to understand
compost ability of some of these
products because we were hearing it from
customers we have a couple of large
employers that have multiple cafeterias
for their staff we have a local hospital
and we've worked with all those campuses
to identify uh composable products and
what makes sense as far as increasing
diversion and and still making a good
end product
and that concludes my presentation
so thank you for your patience and I
apologize for blinking out a couple of
times oh that is okay because your
presentation is so fantastic I really
appreciated it
um if people have questions please put
it in the question and answer box at the
bottom of at least my screen I'm also
going to launch a um a simple uh poll on
Mark's talk I
just want to applaud you because if you
know it takes the community to deal with
the community and I think that actually
you are not a landfill manager you are a
community manager I can't believe how
many people you have and organizations
and types that you've worked with in
order to connect the dots so that waste
is no longer a waste it is a resource
that reinvigorates the community and I
just I just think it's such an
inspiration that that that you're doing
golf courses and Hobby Farms and
restaurant flatware and and um
events based opportunities I I just I I
I I just I I'm rambling
um I have a question how did you get
I've tried to get my grocery store in
New York City where we banned plastic
bags
um to have compostable bags so that uh
our food waste in your city can go in
the compostable bags which then go into
the food waste recycling program
and the the grocery stores refuse
um
I'm just wondering how
how do you approach these community
members
in order to engage them in this process
because you're not using carrot and
stick you're using let's just do it and
and it's really beautiful
so there's a a an Outreach philosophy
that I employ on a number of different
levels over the years I've just I take
classes on Outreach and how to
communicate better to audiences and in
the public and one that works really
well is something called community-based
social marketing
and that method was perfected by a guy
named Doug McKenzie Moore he's a
Canadian and has done amazing things
moving a community in different
directions
an example that we've done here
um we started about five years ago with
a program called
um see if we can see this refill not
landfill
and so for the month of April instead of
focusing on recycling better we focus on
stop making waste completely
um so we ask a number of businesses and
residents to pledge for the month of
April to reduce their waste impacts and
during that month
kovid was a huge Challenge and we
actually had to hit the brakes a little
bit
um but during that month we asked people
to use you know instead of doing things
like compostable bags did you need the
bag and just asking questions every day
do I need this you know back to what
Zach was talking about that Source
production and waste reduction are
really what we should be focusing on and
not so much on how do I compost this
food waste but how do I stop making the
food waste to begin with and then what I
can't avoid that's what I'm managing
um so for the last five years we've
partnered the city of Lebanon has
partnered with a local food co-op that
has three stores we've presented the
concept to a Northeast Cooperative
grocery store we've seen this program
grow in different places so
this is the community-based social
marketing one technique is
um the example that I have that I think
a lot of people can connect with is the
show Candid Camera
and years ago there was this program
called Candid Camera and it was it was a
joke kind of show but it had some
serious psychological and human elements
to it one that sticks out in my mind is
a person is walking into a delicatessen
and there's a sign right on the door
that says don't step on the white
squares and as they walk in there's
white and black squares and at what we
refer to as the moment of decision
you're instructed what to do and so then
they videotape the person kind of
walking in and only stepping on the
black squares the the customer doesn't
ask why they're just told at that moment
to um not not do a particular thing so
we've worked with customers in the area
to
rename their garbage barrels landfill
barrels to make people realize this is
where it's going
um we're doing workshops we're doing and
understanding that everybody learns in
different ways we've developed an app
and the app actually helps people
understand what's compostable and what's
not what's recyclable what's not
um we have a searchable website and so
there's a lot of things lots of moving
Parts with all of this
um and that's the critical part is
there's no like brochure or bumper
sticker that's going to make that move
and even if you replace plastic bags
with compostable bags you may not end up
with the result you're hoping for I've
seen some communities ban plastic bags
only to find a bureaucratic loophole
that allows retailers to actually use
thicker plastic bags as a result
generating more plastic so I've seen
that multiple times because I've been
asked to support plastic bands and I'm
concerned about about them for that very
reason that the end result in many cases
results in more plastic waste generation
so for the last several years for me my
focus has has been less on recycling
better and more on stop making the waste
in the first place you know let's not
talk about how to recycle plastic better
let's stop making it in the first place
or that was long-winded but I'm very
passionate about that
go feed her with your question
thank you so I I think you've given a
hint on on the answer to this but I
I don't remember the exact number but
you're getting something like 10
diversion of food scraps so my question
is
for a really ambitious greenhouse gas
Target you know so for your
kind of uh ideal fantasy of where you'd
like to be and your municipality to be
by 2050
um
you know I'm curious uh your system
seems really well designed for like you
say you for the purpose you're using it
right so but you'll saturate
the capacity to use the compost on your
landfill and on public spaces if you got
up to 90 diversion
um
so I'm just curious
if you can say something about that
scaling issue because you know my
perception is
as we go to more ambitious diversion
goals
we're going to have to
not just tweak the system but but
there'll be new issues that come up so
it's important in any project it's so
critical to identify your goals and
everybody understand those goals if
greenhouse gas reduction is my goal
I might stop composting completely we
have an active gas collection system
which
um captures that gas and is pretty
efficient at destroying
um those greenhouse gases it does
generate some greenhouse gas emissions
as a result but it reduces a lot of the
greenhouse gases so if my focus were 100
greenhouse gases I might say I'm going
to stop composting and just landfill
everything and capture it
um that's one reason why it concerns me
that we see this huge move towards
anaerobic digestion because anaerobic
digestion is merely extracting the
energy from those components and you're
still resulting in a product that in
some cases is not usable it's still
producing a sludge and very often what
we're seeing now in in many of our rural
States is a Banning of land application
of sludges
so as a result anaerobically digested
material ultimately is volume reduced
and then will very likely be landfilled
I've seen a lot of programs that that
are promoting these these energy
programs through anaerobic digestion but
it's still being land filled so although
it is waste reduction by volume it's
still not accomplishing that
but to your question specifically Peter
about saturation
for our area even as rural as it is you
can never get enough compost I am out of
compost and this morning the parks
department contacted me they've got a
project and they needed some compost I
we used all of it on that railroad
project last year so we're in the
process of creating something now
um but it takes time I can't just flick
a switch
um we have a old castle Gravel Pit right
across the street from us they've
approached us and said we'll buy all of
your compost because the state of
Vermont who's a neighbor of ours
requires 25 of their Vermont
Transportation compost start topsoil to
contain compost and to create a comp
topsoil forgive me a topsoil product in
Vermont legally you have to have 25
compost in it and there aren't
sufficient quantities locally to produce
that product so I'm not worried about
distribution of it even on a low value
product scale
um I think what we're going to see is
more and more people wanting more and
more
um organic matter in our soil is
depleting and getting more and more
difficult to find and a great way to
return organic matter to our soil is
through compost I've worked with a known
number of farmers to move away from a
manure spraying operation to move into a
compost operation and then incorporate
compost into their soils because the
spraying contributes to storm water and
very often you know just is so literally
fluid it's just moving off of the soils
compost allows for a greater
incorporation into soils so I don't see
it going away I think it's going to get
more and more of a desired product
soil
the limiting factor that I find and I
think this is why anaerobic digestion is
so popular is carbon
um it really takes some effort and some
some careful planning to make sure
you've got adequate sources of com of
carbon throughout the year you know we
think about leaf and yard waste but
leaves come primarily in the fall
um and you don't want them to break down
so we've encouraged people to use paper
bags if they're collecting them
commercially
and then that retards the decomposition
process by keeping in a paper bag so
they overwinter nicely and then they're
available in the spring when we're we
have a huge shortage of available carbon
okay so Francis asks how did you get the
program started at the landfill I
imagine there were a lot of
complications actually starting
something on that scale so who did you
talk to and what rules policies were in
place that allowed you or had to be put
into place for you to do these things
so when we started composting
over a decade ago the state of New
Hampshire had a very complicated
permitting process
so I used to work for the state of New
Hampshire so I understood the rules and
I understood the bureaucracy of it so I
played with the system a bit
we composted physically on the landfill
for over 10 years so when the state
asked what are you doing with food waste
I'm landfilling it it's always within
the footprint of the landfill so I
didn't need a permit we were the only
landfill doing this in New Hampshire
nobody else was composting food scraps
because it was so complicated but it was
viewed as MSW we managed it within the
footprint of the landfill the end
product was applied to the outside
slopes of the landfill so theoretically
and bureaucratically it was landfilled
but we had removed it from there and
replaced a virgin product with it that's
how we got started and we started very
small scale uh the uh the local hospital
was interested in diverting food scraps
so we worked with them
um getting that program going there was
a local food scrap program at a at a
college that was failing so I I just
approached them
um my employer the city of Lebanon is
extremely supportive of some of these
crazy ideas that I have so far I've not
had any any issues with with the city of
Lebanon they're they're very excited
about what we're doing here has a
positive impact on disposal it's keeping
it local it's on so many levels it's
just it's really working well
um so I'm not flaunting you know the
fact that I went against the rules in
some regard for composting because I
actually approached the state about it
and said this is what I'm going to do
and they said Mark you're absolutely
right you're that's completely within
the bounds because you're controlling
vectors you're controlling leachate
you're you know I was controlling
everything within the footprint of the
landfill so it was an acceptable
practice and it allowed my staff to
learn how to do it so if the if for some
reason we fell down
we're on the landfill it's pretty
forgiving we can make this work so we
would compost along side slopes
so in the when the piles were done all
we did was push them over and just move
them down slope so you know to minimize
movement and it just it
we lost you again
foreign
I don't want to end five minutes early
because of the technical difficulty
there's so much good stuff here while
we're waiting for for Mark to come back
uh hi there great sorry so the end of
the story is I got a permit and we're
we're legal and New Hampshire has
finally we worked quite a bit with the
state of New Hampshire to rewrite their
composting rules I participate in
legislative study committees regularly
um so I'm really engaged with the state
um just to keep things going two weeks
ago I gave a landfilling 101 class to
legislators on what actually is
landfilling that it's not simply burying
things in a hole
um because they're working on new rules
um so a lot of this is just education
but it's also that piece about
community-based social marketing if you
want somebody to do something different
sometimes it's not about convincing them
that this is the right thing to do don't
you understand what's happening
sometimes it's just putting it in front
of them and saying this is the way we're
going like what we did at the farmers
market you don't have an option where
the city had control over a waste
generation we set a policy where all
vendors have to use compostable products
it's either compostable or recyclable
those are your options so we went from
95 percent disposal five percent
diversion in less than two weeks we
literally flipped that I did the same
thing at a local hospital where we
flipped their diversion rate they had a
60 40 split 60 disposal 40 diversion we
changed some of the fiddlings with their
program
um and within two weeks we had 60
diversion and 40 uh disposal so with
some simple tweaking and not this oh
come on you know legislating it and
things like that we were playing on
human norms and social mores and all
those types of things and just moving
people in the direction we wanted them
to go
um and very often we we're creatures of
habit and we're we're gonna follow the
crowd and if you get enough people
moving in a direction a lot of people
are going to come along with so our food
scrap program residential drop-off has
about 300 households participating and
there's nothing making them do it we
created an economic incentive because
it's cheaper
um our community because of the work
we've been doing I think is really very
interested in reducing its waste and
impact on the environment as a result of
years of you know this background
Grassroots work
um but we have a lot of support here
that I know a lot of places don't have
so we have a very unique situation
so I'm just curious how do we start
thinking about these ideas nationally
across the division or the sector of
landfill like
like are there ways in which are avenues
that you can imagine or you can suggest
or direct us to in order to get this
cross fertilization of programs like
yours across state boundaries and then
sort of infiltrate the whole thing so
it's it's really challenging right now I
think we're still figuring out the
impact of covid
um and I know we're all sick of hearing
this
but um it has really impacted the way we
do everything
um the waste we generate is different
you know we're shopping from home more
so there's more cardboard
um people are not like we've seen a huge
increase in construction and demolition
debris people aren't Building Homes
they're remodeling and they're doing it
in some cases themselves or with small
local contractors so it's the way stream
has changed there's this movement
towards local and I know Zach was
talking about that with healthier diets
um
I think some of it is just making sure
people understand some basic principles
um our society has changed considerably
where in the past you know our
grandmother might have taught us how to
can or how to properly you know when you
come home with with hamburger
but you're not going to eat it for a
couple of days throw it in the freezer
that you don't have to you know nothing
some of the solutions are really simple
um I think back to a question that I got
from a resident and it was this woman
called up and she was very upset that we
didn't have a juice box recycling option
for her and she went on and on about
what am I going to do about the juice
box and so I she finished and then I
turned the tables and I said if you're
concerned about the juice box stop
making it make your child juice
out of a concentrate and just give them
a reusable container
she was thrilled with the answer but
never thought of it on her own and I
think that's where we are as a culture
so we really need to I the short answer
Jennifer is I don't have the answer
because stuff has changed so much so
rapidly this paradigm shift is
unbelievable but what hasn't changed is
how we think and function as human
beings and that we want other people to
like us that's one thing so creating
uh local Champions is really important
doing something on a national level I
think is tricky somehow it's got to be
cool or or in
um the stuff that I've seen the programs
we've done here locally I think work
locally because we've worked with so
many different Avenues you know and hit
so many different levels where we have
an employer doing composting in the
cafeteria at work and then there's
composting available here so it's at
it's in different places it's not just
Mark's doing this crazy sticker campaign
there's all these other elements to it
um lots of like I said lots of moving
Parts I
I mean I'd be interested in
participating in something like that I
don't think it's a one-off there's no
Silver Bullet it's literally multiple
Avenues
um at different levels you know I mean
people of you know in the 20s have a
different thought process from the
people in their 30s
um it's very different
um
you know people are like you guys you
know you're working from home I'm
presuming
um it so it's our so much is very
different access to these services are
very different I'd be interested to see
Zach's slides that had stuff from 2018
I'd be interested to see 2021 in 2022
because our waste practices are
different at home than they are at work
because you've got to deal with it
um so it's it's interesting to see that
Dynamic
um but there's a lot there's a lot going
on and I don't think we're done yet but
any last comments you'd like to share
before we end today's video the only
thing I have is is just that um
the waste reduction piece is critical
but that composting plays an amazing
role in not only reducing greenhouse
gases but can in fact have a positive
impact in sequestering
um carbon
um you know and doing regenerative
exercises you know is really a critical
piece of this simply reducing our
emissions is not enough we've got to do
something to remove some of the carbon
out of the atmosphere and get it back
into the soil
um you know and
and go at it that way
um I had mentioned earlier when it was
just the panelists talking that
um I've spent some time just very broad
very Loosely looking into regenerative
farming and how can we incorporate that
into a landfill operation and that's
kind of where some of the food scrap
philosophies have come from
um but also some of the other
philosophies are recyclables in Lebanon
are not exported sometimes we take a hit
financially but we move as much as we
can locally again to reduce
Transportation Footprints so it's a it's
a multi-pronged approach
um and it's not for the faint at heart
it's a it's a considerable amount of
work
um to do so
I'm happy to uh to talk with others
offline
um it's it's obviously a passion of mine
soil health is actually a big passion of
mine and getting waste back into the
soil
um not always should go back into the
soil but organic materials should go
back into the soil as a soil amendment
and improve organic matter in our
depleted soils
this was a wonderful presentation
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu